what I want to do in this video is give
ourselves a basic introduction to the
phenomenon of light and light is at
least to me it is mysterious because on
one level it really defines our reality
it's maybe the most defining
characteristic of our reality everything
we see how we perceive reality is based
on light bouncing off of objects or
bending around objects or diffracting
around objects and then being being
sensed by our eyes and then sending
signals into our into our brain that
create models of the world we see around
us so it really is almost the defining
characteristic of our reality but at the
same time when you really go down to
experiment and observe with light it
starts to have a bunch of mysterious
properties and to a large degree it is
not fully understood yet and probably
the most amazing thing about light or
and well actually there's there's tons
of amazing things about light but one of
the mysterious things is when you really
get down to it and this is actually not
just true of light this is actually true
of almost anything once you get onto a
small enough quantum mechanical level
but light behaves as both a wave and a
particle and this is probably not that
intuitive to you because it's not that
intuitive to me in my life I'm used to
certain things behaving as waves like
sound waves or the waves of an ocean and
I am used to certain things behaving
like particles like like basketballs or
or I don't know my coffee cup I'm not
used to things behaving as both and it
really depends on what experiment you
run in how you observe the light so when
you observe it as a particle and this
comes out of out of einstein's work with
the photoelectric effect and I won't go
into the details here maybe in a future
video when we start thinking about
quantum mechanics you can view light as
a train of particles of a train of
particles moving at the speed of light
which I'll talk about in a second and we
talk we call these particles we call
these particles photons if you view
light in other ways and you see it even
when you when you see light being
refracted by a prism here it looks like
it is a wave it looks like it is a wave
and it has the properties of a wave it
has a frequency
it has a frequency and it has a
wavelength and like other waves the
velocity of that wave is the frequency
times its wavelength now what's even
within even if you ignore this this
particle aspect of light if you just
look at the wave aspect of the light
it's still fascinating because most ways
require a medium to travel through so
for example if I think about how sound
travels through air so let me draw a
bunch of air particles air particles
writing out our sound wave traveling
through the air particles what happens
in a sound wave is you compress some of
the air particles and those compress the
ones next to them and so you have points
in the air that have higher I guess you
could say higher pressure and points
that have lower pressure and you can
plot that so we have high pressure over
here high pressure low pressure high
pressure low pressure and as these
things bump into each other and this
this wave essentially travels to the
right and if you were to plot that you
would see this wave form traveling to
the right but this is all predicated or
this is all based on these part this
this energy traveling through a medium
and I'm I'm used to visualizing waves in
that way but light needs no medium light
needs no medium it note lead needs no
medium light will actually travel
fastest through nothing through a vacuum
and it will travel at an unimaginably
fast speed 3 times 10 to the 8th meters
meters per second and just to give you a
sense of this this is 300 million meters
per second or another way of thinking
about it is it would take light or it
would take light less than a seventh of
a second to travel around the earth or
would travel around the earth more than
seven times in one second so
unimaginably fast and not only is this
just a super fast rate and this is one
or a super fast speed but once again it
tells us that light is something
fundamental to our universe because it's
not just an unimaginable fast speed it
is the fastest bead not just known to
physics but possible in physics so once
again something very unintuitive to to
us in our everyday realm we always
that okay if something is going at some
speed maybe if there was an ant riding
on top of that something it was moving
in the same direction it would be going
even faster but nothing can go faster
than the speed of light it's it's
absolutely impossible based on our
current understanding of physics so it's
not just a fast speed it is the fastest
speed it is the fastest speed speed
possible fastest speed possible and this
right here is an approximation it's
actually two hundred ninety was two
point nine nine something something
times ten to the eighth meters per
second but three times ten to the eighth
meters per second is a pretty good
approximation now within the visible
light spectrum and I'll talk about
what's beyond the visible light spectrum
in a second you're probably familiar
with the colors you maybe you imagine
them as the colors of the rainbow and
rainbows really happened because the
light from the Sun the white light is
being is being refracted by these little
little water particles and you can see
that and maybe a clearer way when you
see light being refracted by a prism
right over here and the different
wavelengths of light so white light
contains all of the all of the visible
wavelengths but the different
wavelengths get refracted differently by
a prism so in this case the higher
frequency wavelengths the violet and the
blue gets refracted more it gets bent
its Direction gets bent more than the
low frequency wavelengths then the Reds
and the oranges then the Reds and the
oranges right over here and if you want
to look at the wavelength of light
they're a visible light it's between 400
nanometers and 700 nanometers and the
higher the frequency the higher the
energy of that light and that actually
goes into when you start talking about
the quantum mechanics of it that the
higher frequency means that each of
these photons have higher energy they
have a better ability to give kinetic
energy to knock off electrons or
whatever else they need to do so higher
frequency let me write that down
higher frequency higher frequency means
higher energy higher energy now I keep
referring to this idea of the visible
light and you might say what is beyond
visible light and what you'll find is
that light is just part of a much
broader phenomenon then it's just the
part that we happen to observe and if we
want to broaden the discussion a little
bit light is just or I should say
visible light is just really part of the
electromagnetic spectrum so light is
really just electromagnetic radiation
electromagnetic magnetic radiation and
everything that I told you about light
just now it has a wave property and it
has particle properties this is not just
specific to visible light this is true
of all of electromagnetic radiation so
at very low frequencies or very long
wavelengths we're talking about things
like radio waves the things that allow a
radio to reach your car the things that
allow allow your your cellphone to
communicate with cell towers microwaves
the things that that that start
vibrating water molecules in your food
so that they heat up infrared which is
what our body releases and that's why
you can detect people through walls with
infrared cameras visible light
ultraviolet light the UV light coming
from the Sun that will give you sunburn
x-rays the the radiation that allows us
to see through the soft material and
just visualize the bones gamma rays the
super-high energy that comes from
quasars and other certain types of
physical phenomena these are all
examples of the exact same thing we just
happen to perceive certain frequencies
of this as visible light and you might
say hey Sal how can we only perceive
certain frequencies of this how can we
only how can we only see these
frequencies and I'll put these literally
we can see those frequencies with our
unaided eye and the reason or at least
my best guess of the reason of that is
that's the frequency where the sun dumps
out a lot of electromagnetic radiation
so it's inundated the earth and if as a
species you wanted to observe things
based on reflected energy a reflected
electromagnetic energy it is most useful
to be able to perceive the things where
there
is the most electromagnetic radiation so
it is possible that in other realities
or other planets there are species that
perceive more in the ultraviolet range
or on the infrared range and even on
earth there are some that perform better
at either end of the range but we see
really well in the in the part of the
spectrum where the Sun just depends to
dump a lot of radiation on us now I'll
leave you there I think that's a pretty
good overview of light and if any of the
thing is any of the stuff seems kind of
unintuitive or daunting or really on
some level confusing this wave particle
duality this idea of a transfer of
energy through nothing and it seems
unintuitive don't worry
it seems unintuitive even for the best
of physicists so you're already you're
already at the leading edge of physics
thinking